NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
>> THANKS, WILLIAM.
ANOTHER GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL
FACING CLAIMS OF COVID
HYPOCRISY.
MAYOR OF AUSTIN, TEXAS NOW
APOLOGIZING, TELLING PEOPLE TO
STAY HOME AND STOP THE SPREAD.
CASEY STEGALL PICKS UP REPORTING
IN DALLAS HERE.
CASEY?
>> YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS UP.
BUT IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND THE
TIME LINES, WE HAVE TO START AT
THE BEGINNING.
WATCH MAYOR STEVE ADLER, THE
MAYOR OF AUSTIN, WATCH HIS PLEA
TO THE PUBLIC FROM A FEW WEEKS
AGO.
>> WE NEED TO STAY HOME, IF YOU
CAN, DO EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO
TRY TO KEEP THE NUMBERS DOWN.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO RELAX.
WE MAY HAVE TO CLOSE THINGS DOWN
IF WE’RE NOT CAREFUL.
>> NOW, YOU NOTICE THE CEILING
WAS SHOWING.
PERHAPS ADLER HAD THE CAMERA
TILTED UP SO PEOPLE CONTINUE SAY
SAND AND PALM TREES.
HE WAS IN CABO, SAN LUCAS,
MEXICO AT HIS TIME SHARE.
BEEN THERE A DAY AFTER FLYING
DOWN ON HIS PRIVATE JET WITH
EIGHT OTHER PEOPLE AFTER HIS
DAUGHTER GOT MARRIED.
IT HAPPENED TO BE AT A TIME WHEN
AUSTIN WAS STRUGGLING WITH A
SPIKE OF NEW CORONAVIRUS
INFECTIONS AND HOSPITALIZATIONS.
LATE YESTERDAY ALL OF THIS NEWS
WAS LEAKING AND STARTED MAKING
THE ROUNDS.
HOURS LATER, YOU GUESSED IT,
ROLL THE TAPE.
>> I’M SORRY I TOOK THAT TRIP.
IT WAS A LAPSE IN JUDGMENT.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW I APOLOGIZE.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT I REGRET
THAT TRAVEL.
I WOULDN’T TRAVEL NOW.
I DIDN’T OVER THANKSGIVING.
I WON’T OVER CHRISTMAS.
AND NO ONE SHOULD.
>> THAT APOLOGY VIDEO GOING ON
TO SAY THAT HE STILL, HOWEVER,
DID NOT VIOLATE ANY ORDERS AND
THAT HE CONSULTED HIS OWN HEALTH
OFFICIALS BEFORE THE WEDDING AND
THE TRIP.
20 GUESTS WERE INVITED TO HIS
DAUGHTER’S WEDDING, WHICH WAS
HELD IN A BOUTIQUE IN AUSTIN
WHEN THE CITY WAS UNDER A STAGE
3 ADVISORY.
TEN GROUPS DISCOURAGED HIM.